the traditional public schools
with whom the teachers union have played
politics
have kept these schools closed have
denied these kids the opportunity to
continue their learning
it is shameful and they have got to get
back
into the classroom
that's education secretary betsy devos
on the importance of getting children
back into the classroom
school lockdowns taking a toll on
students mental and physical health this
many months into the pandemic a family
in maine says their 16 year old son
committed suicide
after he said he felt isolated and was
struggling to cope with the pandemic
now a group of parents along with the
organization called
school choice wisconsin are suing the
city of racine
after it closed its public and private
schools
possibly in defiance of a state supreme
court ruling to prevent
such measures let's go deep on this it
affects so many people across the
country they are watching to see what
happens in wisconsin
jim bender is the president of school
choice wisconsin good to see you jim
first of all what what power
did this entity that closed the schools
and racine
say that it has and does it really have
the power to do that
well in wisconsin we've had an ongoing
debate there's really two layers of
health departments there's the state
health department
and then local units of health
department underneath that and the
statutes govern
those two entities differently we are in
front of the supreme court now
for dane county uh home of uw madison
where the local health official closed
down schools in dane county the
supreme court stepped in and said no
only the statewide
uh health officer can do that that's the
legal argument in front of them they put
an injunction on dane county
then racine followed up and said we're
going to close all the schools in racine
and we have gone to court to have the
injunction get extended from dane county
to racine county to say no this is under
review
you can't close schools just because of
a local health order
and surprisingly the local health
department and the city of racine
has ignored the injunction that the
supreme court extended from dane county
to racine county
so now you're talking about schools that
have been operating
in the fall in a very safe manner
arbitrarily closed from now until
sometime into january
again decisions not based necessarily on
science and data
but on politics and other factors and
that's what i want to ask you about i i
do want to get into the politics of this
because the science is not there
right and we're finding out the science
is not there for the outdoor banding
they were trying to do on on the west
coast in l.a county a judge just said
that
the science is not there and and you see
the arbitrary nature of
in one county versus the other whether
they have the power or not
they shut schools down so how do you
fight this what what
what statistics do you use if they're
not going to use science are you
because it's on your side absolutely
right and i think
what all the schools in the state have
been arguing for is a local approach
meaning a school level approach so if i
look at one school renaissance lutheran
they've been open operating safely 250
total students they had 142 of them
in person following mitigation protocols
social distancing masks things were you
know
obviously kept very clean inside the
school they had a handful of positive
cases
but those were students that were
infected outside the school and because
of their cohorts and their mitigation
there was no
transfer of covet inside the stool and
that's all these schools are asking for
is the ability to have a hybrid approach
that fits their student body their
families their workforce
as it goes forward and that's what most
schools have been doing public and
private around the state of wisconsin
when it comes to creating a safe
learning environment
these one-size-fits-all approaches that
are meant
that are meant to close down all the
schools are not serving the kids and
that's the most important part here
besides the academic slide
what you're seeing in a situation in
racine there was a young girl that wrote
an article
and a column to the health department
that said
listen when the schools got shut down
not only were they not allowed into the
safe learning environment of the school
but grandparents had to take over the
process of virtually
and they had 15 students inside a single
home so now you're talking about a
student that's at a larger cohort more
people
inside a home than she would have been
around in her own school
not following social distancing so it
again it's not the science not the
rational thoughts not the data that's
going into this
in racine what you've seen in the last
10 years dramatic advancement of the
racine parental choice program
where now you've got more than 30
percent of the publicly funded students
are in private schools you've seen a
pretty dramatic decline in enrollment in
the local district school
the mayor of racine is very tight with
the local teachers union
we've had multiple occasions of this
happening across the
teachers union influence over cova
decisions
overrides and supersedes and the local
positivity rate
or hospitalization rate data so you've
got this political overtone to this
which is kind of contextually happening
over the last 10 years
but you're not focused on what's for
kids whether it's for families
and done at a very specific level so
it's frustrating for the schools to have
gone
extra efforts to create safe learning
environments
i i see how the politics weave
themselves in there and
and what your fight is next so in racine
you want to be able to say
you can't close the schools there's an
injunction against doing that in
nearby dane county that's a higher level
decision
and maybe in this time there's a window
for kids to go back to school
jim that would be the hope and then
hopefully vaccines come along and we're
in a better stead
after the beginning of the year we can
start to look back at the science
wow you've got a big job it's for the
most important cause it's for our babies
trying to learn in school thank you for
your fight in racine wisconsin keep us
posted
thank you very much